[Music]
welcome to stick to football live on NFL
draft Eve
that's right Wednesday before the 2020
NFL Draft kicks off and today on the
show myself Melo and Connor are going to
give you our final draft predictions
make sure and write these down because
they will be correct
guaranteed also we have the best
all-around defender of the night SM is
the entire class Antoine Winfield jr.
legacy player shoulda won the Thorpe
Award will be on the show with us and of
course Bill's drafts on draft questions
if you're watching this in the Bleacher
Report app and you should be if you're
not I would like an explanation why to
give me that explanation download the
bleach Report app leave your comment
below let us know why you can also leave
your draft on draft questions there
I am Matt Miller he is mellow no last
name that's how good he is and Connor
Rogers is in lovely Hoboken New York
today guys I am jacked up because the
draft is tomorrow my tenth draft a
bleach report I'm gonna get myself a
cake I'm a little excited it's nice that
this day comes around it's kind of a
relief afterwards you just get to sit
back and enjoy a couple days before you
have to immediately do a recap on Friday
morning Monday morning that mock draft
comes out for 2021 not joking
Monday morning and I can't wait boys I
mean this is Christmas tomorrow what
else are we waiting for we've been
talking about this class for a really
really long time so let's get this thing
going
let's do it actually had a dream last
night that I did a mock draft and forgot
to put Justin Herbert in the mock draft
I think your guys hate for him is
affecting me and Melo we are gonna start
with you your final predictions we each
get two of them two of them your final
prediction for Thursday night how's it
gonna go and I'm gonna start with our
guy - uh right here there's a lot of
buzz going around with the dolphins and
what they're gonna do are they gonna
take Justin Herbert are they gonna trade
up and take a tackle no all that is a
smokescreen the Miami Dolphins will be
taking to with their first pick probably
at number five if not number three I
don't believe all the news that we hear
coming out here I think they're gonna
look at this guy and say this is one of
the best quarterback prospects we've
seen in a long time he just happens to
be in the same class as Joe burrow but
they're gonna make the right decision
here go with your quarterback keep him
healthy
tectum help they could take two
offensive lineman with their two
first-round picks that they have left
after two uh I think this the right move
for this franchise and this is what the
fan base has been wanting for a very
long time you're right about the fan
base they are wild if you tweet I don't
know if you guys have done this tweet
the Dolphins won't take to uh not even
though you think they shouldn't take to
just that they won't mentions for the
rest today absolute trash from Dolphins
fans they started the hashtag tank for
to up it feels like two years ago and
Melo I know Connor is with you the heat
things too it should be the pick maybe
thinks he will be the pick I'm gonna go
ahead and say not so fast to quote my
guy Lee Corso on this just in a Herbert
will be the pick by the Miami Dolphins
at number five overall I know that we
live in a world of what we would do
those are our rankings our mock drafts
are based on what we are hearing and it
could be an elaborate smokescreen I hope
it is quite frankly because I think - it
is leaps and bounds better but six foot
six 240 pounds rocket right arm I've
actually heard the Dan Marino is getting
involved in this you know he does a lot
of quarterback evaluating for them I've
heard that Dan has just said this guy
looks like I did I know too was trying
to wear my number but Justin Harbor has
the arm strength more mobility - Dan did
that's for dang sure as you see here
pull it down get the endzone and it has
really dominated the pre-draft process
no injury question so again not what I
would do I would draft Toa and then take
two tackles like you said my legs I I
think it's all smokescreen to try to get
their guy and they've done a very good
job this offseason of leading us in
different directions even today with the
tackle I want to be wrong you're going
to be okay yeah that's what I've been
saying for a very long time I think this
builds up with Herbert and I know
they've done their homework on him I
know they want to improve their
offensive line I'm with you there Melo I
do think it's gonna be - and it is gonna
be really really exciting to see how it
plays out but my first prediction here
is the team that picks right before them
at number four that is the New York
Giants and guys I think they're gonna
take Jedrek wills I really really do I
know we've gone in circles with this
offensive line class we've talked about
whether Isaiah Simmons for them a
defensive pick who talked about Tristan
works for them maybe Makai Becton Andrew
Thomas but wills to me is the best guy
in this class
I know we make a lot of Dave gentleman
jokes but I do think he gets this one
right and I also think wills can come in
and play on the right side for the New
York Giants for a day from day one as
you saw him do here for Alabama in the
SEC at a very high level so they have
nate solder on the left I know they
signed chemcam Fleming who I think will
be a swing guy for them you get really a
surefire dominant run blocker clean pass
protector and Jedrek wills for the
Giants yeah I agree to you I hope this
happens I also think there's a good
chance it will which is I do believe why
as we're sitting here Wednesday
afternoon you're hearing that oh maybe
the Dolphins want to trade up for a
tackle there's a reason those types of
rumors leak out Jedrek wills we all
agree the consensus number one tackle in
the 2020 class I think it's very
importantly you said there plug and play
right tackle because they actually think
Nate Soldier is gonna be fine on the
left side if that is a pan out we could
see wills play on the blind side for
Daniel Jones
Melo one more final prediction for the
2020 draft I'm goat bold prediction and
I don't think either if you guys even
believe this I'm sure you've seen in our
rundown I do not think the Raiders will
be selecting at number 12 or number 19 I
think last year we saw may ox say all
right new here I'm gonna stay at number
four and I'm gonna take my guy not this
year I think this guy is gonna be moving
some pics he's got the first rounders to
do it why not go up and get if you want
a quarterback or if you want a receiver
if you want to get your hands on Isiah
Simmons I think we're gonna see Mack
make some moves here and they will be
picking up pick number 12 or 19 tomorrow
night well they don't have second-round
picks something I remember so they could
bounce back get some extra picks or they
could package their two ones like you
said you go up Isiah Simmons and that
Raiders defense would just be a little
he'd be too good to be true Chiefs fan
over here would absolutely hate it I
think it would be fantastic that is a
great fit all right speaking of the
Oakland Raiders here's a player that's
been a target for them CJ Henderson
cornerback out of Florida the Raiders
will not have a chance to draft him
unless they trade up my final prediction
my guy CJ goes top ten overall Melo we
could be looking at the Carolina
Panthers at seven
looking at the Jacksonville Jaguars at
nine or it seemed like the Atlanta
Falcons trading up from 16 overall to
get mister locked down himself
6 1/2 of
for three nights making time they say
you can't tackle he can tackle them come
down you know a lot of people said this
was a to cornerback class for a very
long time and I'll tell you one guy who
didn't me I love what CJ henderson can
do and I absolutely do think that he
will go top ten tomorrow night there's
just too much there he has all the
traits to checks all the boxes a did
catch that one but he's got great ball
production too
I think he's gonna be a great corner in
the next house to close the gap he tries
to bait people because he's so fast and
so long if he closes that gap in face I
think where I see him become a I
compared them to Marcus Peters these
become a very good corner
yeah and Peter is a very feast or famine
guy and I think we saw that from
Henderson plenty of times this season
but to tie a little bonus prediction
here guys I think there's gonna be a run
on corners tomorrow night and that's
gonna start with JEP Acuna it's gonna
continue with CJ Henderson but when we
get into the 20s I think we're gonna see
a Jay Terrell come off the board I think
we can see Christian pulling maybe
trevone digs so that list is gonna go on
and on jaylen Johnson might even get in
the action but my final real prediction
here right now is that those trade
returns as we see a lot of potential
trades in the top 15 will be low I think
the teams that hold the picks or the
teams that want to come up actually have
the leverage and the teams that hold the
picks are dying to get out of the spot
and everybody knows that otherwise the
Lions would have been out of three by
now I think when you look at the Browns
or even the Panthers both of those teams
in the top ten they're looking to get
out and the Broncos the Eagles the
Falcons they're not gonna have to pay a
king's ransom to go up well you have to
maybe give up your second-round pick or
maybe you'll have to give up a
combination of a third and a fourth
short but when you're looking into 2021
capital premium Capital first-round
picks multiple day two picks I don't
think those will be included in the
conversations I think it's very notable
as we get closer to the draft we hear
more and more teams want to trade back
you know it's Detroit would trade back
the Giants would trade back it seems
like everyone is willing to move back
and like you said Connor it dilutes the
market you're driving down the asking
price because everyone is willing to
trade back those are our final
predictions of great you can drop yours
right here in the comments if you're
doing this in the BR app and you
should be don't forget to follow all
three of us in the app at FL Jeff Scott
at what is yours at mellow doubles
Ovilus ml o w7 in at Connor who somehow
got the greatest to username in the app
today's show is sponsored by the
upcoming PlayStation 5 the official
console of that one can your
neighborhood who gets all the new
technology before anyone else that's my
kids with high powered graphics and a
brand new spaceship inspired controller
the new console will feature games like
Madden 22 which sources tell me will
feature Connor Rogers on the cover as he
hopes to break the Madden curse and get
the New York Jets to eight and eight add
me on PlayStation at NFL Draft Scout
challenged me to a game of madden but
one rule you have to play as the
Washington Redskins
alright guys yesterday we were fortunate
to catch up with one of our favorite
defenders in the NFL Draft we're gonna
be wearing different clothes he's gonna
be wearing something fresh that's
Antoine Winfield jr. seven interceptions
last year for the gopher take it away
Antoine Winfield Minnesota star safety
Antoine Winfield junior joins us here on
stick to football live one of the best
seasons of any defensive back the 2019
season Antoine I have to ask you from a
personal level though you're from The
Woodlands Texas mom and dad go to Ohio
State you end up at Minnesota how does
that happen where you don't go to Texas
which hurts me as a longhorn fan but you
don't go to Ohio State either what you
think a lot of Buckeye fans are still a
little upset about yeah so yeah both my
parents went to Ohio State and you know
growing up I was raised up like that so
I always dream to go him so I'll stay
well coming out of high school I wasn't
heavily recruited so I didn't get
recruited by them and um you know I
lived in Minnesota for nine years before
hoop it out here to Texas
and um I had a friend that had committed
to Minnesota at the time and I never
would have thought I would have been
playing football up there and when I'll
be convinced me to go and take a visit
with him I ended up taking a visit and
fell in love with the place and it was
the best decision I made
that's pretty awesome really I'm a big
Gophers fan I wanted to ask you about
the Thorpe Award because I don't know
about you I'm still pissed off you
didn't win the Thorpe Award last year
how about yourself
yeah that was also one thing but I want
to do um plan at the collegiate level is
get the tour no that's always been a
dream of mine as well after seeing my
dad do it but you know unfortunately
wasn't part of it but um you know I
really look at it as a negative you know
this is something that you know how it
just wasn't a part of but it won't
change anything I think now he's might
be out for safety drafted anyway I mean
Antwon watching you play watching you
play I mean the amount of plays you make
on the field diagnosing plays before
they even happen it reminds me so much
of the honey badger is there anyone else
obviously you got your dad there to
watch but is there anyone else there you
watch that you really model your game
after yeah I used to watch Thomas and Ed
Reed I'll say those are two of the guys
that I used to watch too growing up and
seeing how they were always around the
ball you see both the gods being the
post breaking them running had the feel
to go get interception and things like
that so that's just some things I try to
add into my game as well after watching
those guys do it okay I'm gonna ask them
the Seahawks helmet over your shoulder
you just mentioned watching a lot of
Earl Thomas are you somehow a Seahawks
fan after your pops plan for the Vikings
probably most most the time you get to
watch him play no I'm actually in my
brother's room my brother's a Seahawks
fan so that's why I got that huge logo
right above my ear so is he gonna switch
teams when you get drafted Thursday
night or Friday night where I'm you end
up is he switching or is he gonna ride
with the Seahawks hopefully he's
switching I think he's gonna switch and
just ride it out with me
I don't know I I'm gonna go a hot take
here I think maybe you just end up in
Seattle and everybody wins are there any
other teams that maybe you see yourself
as a best fit for not one in particular
I feel like whatever team I go to
they're gonna use me and that free
safety or nickel roll and not play that
interchangeably and I'm not flying all
teams have that role that they need us
accepted play in the field so on
whatever team picks me up I fire playing
anybody system obviously a lot of
different teams talking to you this time
of year it's been different because of
face time zoom calls whatever they've
been doing to get to know you a little
better what's the one thing you find
teams are consistently asking you what
do they want to know about Antoine
Winfield jr. yeah they want to know what
position that I think that I'm gonna
play the next level and I told them I
can play any position on the back end of
the defense Corner nickel or safety and
they're trying to pretty much just
figure out with the best videos for me
and I'm up for that
now one thing that pops up I think
anybody who has evaluated you you have
to address the injuries you know you
missed a decent amount of time I think
over two years with injuries is that
something a lot of teams are asking you
about how do you try to explain to them
that as a smaller guy that you aren't
injury prone you know missing a lot of
time in 2017 or 2018 but then you come
back this year all big 10 consistence
all-americans seven interceptions how do
you try to explain to them that that's
the player they're getting yeah you know
it's football you know football 100
percent injury risk sport you're gonna
get hurt playing this game you know both
my injuries were nothing that I could do
differently to make them to change them
you know therefore the accident it was
my hamstring and then a ligament my foot
and I'm it's just something I have to
happen and there's nothing I can do to
go back and change it or anything but I
don't look at it as a negative this is
football that's what happens injuries
come with the sport
yeah I think that's definitely the case
let's ask more questions about Minnesota
I know our listeners love Minnesota
questions who's the best receiver on
that team you had two of them I would
have to go with both great receivers
oversee Bateman and Tyler Johnson but I
have to go inside Johnson he's a dog
going up against him for the last four
years you know we came in together we've
been competing ever since we got on
campus and he's a dude man he has great
routes a great hands
smart player and he just makes plays
every time he's on the field
what was it like being there during a
time where Minnesota turned into you
know not an average program but a really
good program it felt like this year
under PJ fleck you guys had everything
working and it wasn't like oh there's a
tough Minnesota team it was like oh this
is a Minnesota team that means business
every single week what was it like just
being a part of really a culture shift
and that kind of mindset change for the
Gophers it was an awesome experience you
know coming in you know we always had
goals that we want to say like we won't
want to change you know go for football
the way people viewed it coming in as a
freshman and I'm just going through that
transition with different culture
changes with - there's two different
cultures and steps it was just
incredible you know there was a lot of
digging at first when a new coaching
staff came but I feel like everything
cause it's clicked together this year
and everybody was on the same mission
they had the same goal in mind which is
the reason why we have the success that
we had this year
hey I mean it's definitely been
remarkable to see what pj fleck has done
their last question for before we let
you get back what is your draft night or
draft weekend gonna look like because
you're not going to Vegas are you doing
the zoom camera in your house for the
the broadcast you're just hanging out
with mom dad and brother what is your
Thursday Friday gonna look like yeah I'm
just gonna be here with the family
right here at home you know we have it
Jack's way this year they're virtually
doing it so I got the camera set up in
my living room where I'm going to have
it so people can watch and you know I'm
just gonna
well we wish you the best of luck
eating's been a blast watching you play
the last this last season they said
seven interceptions three sacks and s
Connor said a lot of Tiran Matthew to
your game we appreciate you taking time
to join us here on stick fotomat good
luck with the draft process and good
luck with your gonna fill career you got
three really big fans right here thank
you very much I appreciate you guys
they're called the Kota Prescott hello
work this thing
hello mr. Dodds hey bud just calling for
our daily contract negotiation how about
four years twenty million a year and
I'll throw in a half a dozen oil rigs
I want thirty five million dollars a
year oh you're serious
I deserve it sir I'm a great leader okay
how about 25 million and I'll let you
add a fifth play in the Mike McCarthy's
flavor are you having another uh no I
made this eye brochure myself good we
need to be socially distant okay here
let me add Zeke what's up Jerry hey Z
tell Jack that we want him on the team
hey DAC we want you on the team
you paid Zeke you paid him Ari I need to
get what's mine oh no sir you're old
you're just imagining things again I do
sometimes think of the nineties but it
makes me so happy it's a different time
now Jared Goff got thirty three and a
half million I'm better than him right
right okay maybe I can convince Amaro to
give me back someone on your million how
about thirty six mil and I about you to
my next illegal party how do we get
invited to a dak Prescott Throwdown
that's what I want to know or even to
hang out with Jerry Jones the ghost in
cowboy state oh my god get us on the RV
get us on the bus that's what we need to
happen thanks again to Antwon went to
junior for joining us here on stick to
football
hopefully we hear his name called
Thursday night not Friday night but guys
we end every show here with draft on
draft questions we're gonna take three
of those Danny Sauter wants to know if
you had to predict one player in your
top 15 sliding on draft night who
wouldn't be
I'm gonna sneak in here as I read the
question to go first I think DeAndre
swift unfortunately and he is my number
15 overall player I love DeAndre swift I
just think we see running backs fall
down the board guys where maybe we see
one go late first round maybe to the
Miami Dolphins maybe to the Kansas City
Chiefs the mellow it feels like John
drew Swift not because of anything you
did wrong we're not worried about our
medicals or anything just the
devaluation of
position and I'm maybe gonna drop I'm
looking at my big board I haven't in
Tovar all I really like deandre Swift
you might not go in the first round
though so I agree with you I'll throw
out a shocker for you guys I think Derek
Brown is a guy that we could see
definitely slip in this process he
doesn't get after the quarterback at an
elite level he's not gonna be a pass
rusher in the NFL so are you gonna take
a guy like that in the top 10 top 15
when you can find that kind of
production later he's not gonna come in
and be an Aaron Donald I like his game
but I do think that he could fall out of
that top 15 probably still goes first
around but I wouldn't be surprised if we
see guys like him and Kinlaw both slide
down the draft board I think the very
obvious answer for me is the same as you
guys the Andre Swift 11th overall for me
in the top 15 I don't think he goes in
the first round but to get away from
consistently saying him I'm gonna go
with Isaiah Simmons a guy that is at
luck as a top 10 player and I don't I
could see a scenario where he falls the
Jacksonville follows the Cleveland maybe
a run on wide receivers and tackles is
really going full throttle and we're
sitting there and saying we know Isaiah
Simmons is a great player but a lot of
these teams did not need a linebacker
safety and maybe he ends up falling
further than we thought so if you're
looking for a guy that's not a running
back that's gotten a lot of hype I think
it would be him yeah it some guy named
left Coe I don't know you guys ever
heard of them okay guy has one name left
Coe he's gonna be hosting the draft show
with us Thursday night Friday night
Saturday morning make sure you update
your bleach report happen join us for
live coverage of 2020 draft he would ask
and this is a similar question so give
me different names
who's your top ranked player that won't
go round one again I like to cheat and
steal here I'm gonna go save your
McKinney my number 22 overall player top
safety in the class I think we're seeing
that position because of the depth
actually pushed some guys down my seven
or MRF comes out tomorrow morning I had
a very hard time finding a landing spot
for Xavier McKinney that was close to
where I actually think he's valued at
yeah and I won't cheat I'll go different
than the running backs - I'm gonna go
receiver though and I'm gonna go with T
Higgins ice I'm still believer in
Hagen's thank you hear what he can do
but I don't think he goes in the first
round tomorrow night I think he's gonna
be a Friday guy probably at the top of
that second round but still a lot of
teams are coming out and even
saying there's a lot of value at
receiver after these four guys there's a
big group in this tier that could go and
still be very productive starters so I
think we see a guy like T Higgins
despite the size and his ability to
catch the ball fall into that second
round come Friday night I'm gonna go
with the guy that's a familiar face
somebody we just had on the show and
that's Antoine Winfield jr. I have him
20th overall I am not a believer that he
goes in the first round it might be
because of what you heard a little bit
about the medical issues in 2017 2018 I
think this guy is a phenomenal player
but once again would I be a little
surprised if a team takes him with the
top 25 pick or even a night one pick I
would be a little bit
yeah Antoine unfortunately could see us
live because of medicals in a year where
he's not able to go in and do those
private visits the workouts and maybe
it's the Seahawks helmet behind him
maybe maybe that's what maybe he just
goes to the CR yeah maybe he knows maybe
they're watching today and Pete Carroll
says you know what I looks pretty damn
good let's pull the trigger on that
piece do they need another safety right
balki 7399 our last draft on draft
question of the day is there a
possibility the Miami Dolphins don't
take a quarterback this year but build
up their roster and go for Trevor
Lawrence or Justin fields in 2021 I mean
I love the idea of the chaos theory here
but two things you can only kick that
can so far down the road before your
owner says it's time to win some games
then I need a quarterback in the future
to mark it around and secondly I hate to
be the pessimist we might not have
college football next year so do you
want to wait on a guy like a Trevor
Lawrence who maybe will have taken an
entire year off of football it's an
unprecedented situation please stay home
so that we can have football in the fall
but I think betting on anything 2021
right now is premature yeah it's a
little bit risky is there a possibility
though yeah I do think there is a
possibility I think they could look at a
guy like Ryan Fitzpatrick and say we can
win enough games with him maybe we'll
see what we have with Josh Rosen still
and if not we'll put ourselves in
position to go grab a pretty talented
class I don't want to look ahead just
yet Connor will kill me but that 2021
draft class looks pretty good at
quarterback so yes I could see the
Dolphins saying we're gonna wait let's
see what we have here with Fitzpatrick
let's build a team
around him I would be surprised to
happen I think they're gonna get a
quarterback in the strap guys and I
think it's gonna be - if not - they will
find somebody who knows maybe even Jalen
Hertz with one of their second-round
picks so I would be floored if they
don't walk out of this draft class with
the guy we think is gonna take over
after Ryan Fitzpatrick right now and
that would be asking a lot of patience
from the fan base that I think has
already been pretty patient after what
we would consider mailing it in this
year I know they played hard for Brian
Flores
but the roster they put out on the field
for him was not enough so I think the
Dolphins will be taking a quarterback
and I think Dolphins fans deserve to not
have to wait remember Ryan Tannehill was
like a consolation prize with Andrew
Luck and rg3 off the board was like well
we have to draft a quarterback
we'll take Ryan Tannehill and Adam GaSe
ruined him we know that now but they
need like someone they can be excited
about not someone they got you know kid
looking at this roster what this front
office has done I don't think they're in
a position to take a quarterback next
year I think this is gonna be a pretty
damn good flag with a lot of pics that
can come in and help I think you take
your quarterback now because you're not
gonna be picking top ten next year
that's a hot take right have to pick
that's maybe the Texans are picking top
ten then they get and they hit two picks
next year alright that is our show do
not forget Thursday night you can catch
myself Connor and Adam left go right
here in the Bleacher Report app also on
youtube be streaming every pic analysis
of every pic we're not just gonna focus
on Jill burrow all night we're gonna
break every pig down for you every team
will do that Thursday night Friday night
and then for rounds 4 & 5 on Saturday
morning so make sure you have downloaded
the Bleacher Report app to do that and a
special treat for you guys coming out
Friday afternoon a podcast only version
of stick to football where we recap
night 1 of the draft look at some of our
favorite picks from round one will get
mellow on the horn with this maybe we'll
let him talk about 2021 a little bit
before we it's gonna happen that's
before Monday like he's gonna have a top
20 big board out for next year alright
that is our show make sure you follow us
in the app and on twitter at NFL draft
Scout at mellow and at Connor Jay Rogers
we appreciate you guys draft is here
tomorrow night baby we
ready to go
[Music]